all right joining me now is the man
himself Jonathan Turley George
Washington constitutional law professor
and Fox News contributor Jonathan good
to see you all right so Professor thank
you Sean expound upon that point if you
would why might this get worse for Joe
Biden in the end
well you know there was a curious
statement out of the White House that
this information is personal because
this is the personal residence of uh the
president
that dog won't hunt I mean you really
don't have an argument that this is now
a purely personal residence when you've
stored highly classified documents there
so this is Ed at best an investatory
scene but you can't just say that
because it's the private residence that
Congress has no right to find out who
had access to an area that may have
compromised National Security so once
that that wire was tripped by finding
those documents in the garage Congress
clearly has an oversight interest in
knowing who was in that house and
whether there might have been a
compromising of of national security
information now if they don't have a log
then they the Congress is allowed to
pursue other means to acquire that
information they can seek to interview
family and staff those interviews will
occur under the penalty of perjury or
making false statements to Congress uh
so this doesn't change the ability of
Congress to pursue this information can
you talk to me about the defenses that
have been thrown out there because Joe
Biden says as part of his defense I I
take classified documents seriously
others have said it was a mistake that
Joe Biden had the documents at his
residence or Biden is cooperating with
the doj do any of those defenses
actually work in this potential crime
well the the inadvertent defense is
crumpled fairly quickly after it was
first raised it's hard to make an
inadvertent defense when you have
documents that presumably uh were taken
around 2017 when he left uh office as
vice president and then appeared to be
divided and distributed to different
spots the question is why would you have
that division unless these documents
were being used for some purpose now
that purpose could be one of a number of
things but the most obvious would be the
use on uh to be used on the book that
device then vice president was working
on which included subjects like Ukraine
but you know we don't know that but
there's other questions raised by the
most recent disclosures you know the the
last statement was that various
documents were missed in the search of
the residents I thought that was really
perplexing because I've worked with
classified material for over three
decades they are usually held in a
folder that has a very pronounced border
usually red or yellow or striped and
then across the front is in bold letters
of classification it's really hard to
miss if you're looking through a pile so
the question is whether some of these
documents were not in their folders now
if that's the case it gets even more
serious because it would meant that
someone had to remove a document from a
folder that person clearly then knew
that they were classified documents
there and that they were they were
interacting with a classified document
it may not want those questions we don't
know who had access to the documents and
whether they had clearance or not but
let me get to this because some in
Washington think this investigation is a
completely open and shut case watch this
this isn't a particularly complex
investigation the three sites what it
looks like now you know an office space
two residences to go out there figure
out if all the classified information
has been recovered who the people were
who had access to it all the
circumstances by which it came to be
placed there shouldn't take a lot of
time Jonathan Peters truck is back in
and he thinks uh that this isn't that
complex of an investigation but probably
not for the reasons he thinks what's
your take
right well I find it really good quite
remarkable that everyone came out and
said look there's no evidence of any uh
anything other than inadvertents here
there's no evidence at all the White
House has refused to answer any
questions the evidence we have seems to
go against inadvertence but you really
don't know but what's really astonishing
is how all of these people are coming
forth and saying look this pretty much
you know the record as it stands shows
in advertence what record you have at
most you have a group of documents that
were divided for some reason and sent to
different locations I if the president
interacted with those documents then he
shatters this defense and more
importantly it makes these recent
statements look like an effort to
deceive the public and the FBI now do we
know any of that no but all of these the
pronouncements that there's nothing to
see here is odd because we haven't seen
virtually anything thing at all yeah
based on nothing Professor Turley thanks
for joining me I appreciate it I'll be
smart hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else